und die gesamtgemengelage wollen wir
jetzt heute noch besprechen mit der
sicherheits expertin der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik mit claudia
majors schönen guten morgen guten morgen
schauen wir mal auf die
gesamtgemengelage wir wissen im grunde
es ist tag 13 des angriffs wir haben es
eben gerade auch gehört offenbar kommt
die russische armee nicht so vorwärts
wie präsident putin sich das
wahrscheinlich geplant hatte wie ist
ihre einschätzung
es sieht tatsächlich so aus dass der
russische vormarsch nicht so nicht so
einfach nicht so schnell und nicht so
gut voranschreitet wie gedacht aber das
heißt nicht dass russland von dem ziel
abgerückt wäre die ukraine unter
kontrolle zu bringen das konnten in den
letzten tagen sehen ja es geht nicht so
schnell wie gedacht aber es gibt
überhaupt keinen zurückgehen de facto
sondern es gibt er noch ein investieren
darauf kiew einzunehmen und die ukraine
unter kontrolle zu bringen das heißt die
russische seite bleibt ganz dezidiert
bei ihrem ziel die ukrainische seite
sagt aber genau so dezidiert wir werden
nicht aufgeben wir werden die ukraine
nicht aufgeben wir werden weiterhin für
die souveräne ukraine kämpfen das heißt
wir haben zwei parteien die um so mehr
in ihren positionen festhalten und das
führt auch dazu dass wir den letzten
tagen gesehen haben dass nämlich der
krieg immer brutaler wird und mit immer
mehr humanitären leiter einhergeht und
es wird auch dazu dass man keine
annäherung in den gesprächen offenbar
sieht jetzt haben sie gesagt die
russische seite möchte die ukraine unter
ihre kontrolle kriegen was kann denn
überhaupt das ziel sein denn selbst wenn
die ukraine sozusagen erstmal unter
kontrolle wäre ist es ja schwer
vorstellbar dass die russische armee
jetzt für immer dann in der ukraine
stationiert bleibt wenn man sich die
russischen position ansieht kann man so
so grob vier ziele sehen das eine ist
kiew einzunehmen traditionell die
hauptstadt einzunehmen damit das land zu
kontrollieren
das zweite ist ein systemwechsel
herbeizuführen wir hatten jetzt eine
demokratie oder wir haben jetzt eine
demokratisch gewählte regierung und
wahrscheinlich hat russland ihrem sinne
marionettenregierung oder nimbuzz allen
staaten militärregierung aufzubauen das
dritte ziel läuft unter dem russischen
euphemismus entnazifizierung dessen ganz
schreckliches wort das heißt austausch
der alten eliten und das vierte ziel
läuft unter dem russischen euphemismus
entmilitarisierung klingt harmlos heißt
aber de facto die infrastruktur so zu
zerstören dass die ukraine auch nicht
mehr handeln kann das heißt wenn man es
klar macht ein vasallenstaat der von
russland abhängig ist die zerstörung der
infrastruktur das sehen wir gerade auch
schon massiv die zivilisten versuchen
zum teil zu fliehen jetzt ist in der
diskussion ob es so genannte flucht
korridore geben kann jetzt ist nicht
ganz klar
das heißt von russischer seite offenbar
dass die menschen nur nach russland oder
nach belarus kommen können jetzt ist
natürlich die frage ob diese menschen
dahin wollen denn die menschen die
versuchen ja geradezu fliehen von der
russischen aggression
deswegen wird es auch von der
ukrainischen seite abgelehnt wie
schätzen sie diese diese flucht
korridore ein also im prinzip sind
humanitäre korridore eine gute idee weil
sie erlauben den den zivilisten aus
kriegsgebieten zu flüchten und sie alle
um gegebenenfalls auch humanitäre hilfe
also alles von medikamenten bis
bis wasser oder ähnliches nahrungsmittel
in krisengebiete zu bringen also im
prinzip ist das gut was wir jetzt sehen
von russland das eigentlich um
vergiftetes angebot nämlich das angebot
aus den aus den städten raus zu gehen
oder aus den kriegsgebieten raus zu
gehen aber nach russland wo sie
eigentlich nicht hin wollen und die
große sorge ist dass man diese mittel
natürlich propagandistisch
ausgeschlachtet und sagt guck mal die
wollen nach russland fliehen und das
passt in dieses ganze propaganda bild
von russland rein dass die ukraine
angeblich befreit werden würde das heißt
aus meiner sicht das ist ein ganz
perfides vergiftetes angebot was keinen
nicht wirklich den leuten und ich
wirklich den humanitären hilfe die
monetäre notlage helfen soll ich finde
das ganz schrecklich also eigentlich
auch richtig dieses angebot nicht
anzunehmen man müsste versuchen das
angebot so zu drehen dass es wirkliche
korridore gibt dass sie in die ukraine
flüchten können dass sie nach westen
flüchten können es gibt ja ein angebot
von ukrainischer seite wo diese
korridore hin gehen sollten es ist ganz
wichtig dass man versucht diese
humanitäre hilfe diese notlage zu
lindern aber mit ehrlichen und ernst
gemeinten angeboten jetzt ist es
momentan so dass vor allem von
ukrainischer seite immer gehofft wird
dass doch noch diese flugverbotszone
eingerichtet wird also weil man eben
sagt von oben die bomben das ist
momentan das was am meisten zerstört
auch an infrastruktur die nato sagt aber
bisher ganz klar dass sie das nicht
machen wird ist das die richtige
strategie
es ist eine ganz harte antwort aber ich
glaube dass das die richtige strategie
ist wir müssen verstehen dass eine
notlösung oder eine dieses diese den
himmel zuzumachen
heißt nicht nur man guckt so ein
bisschen das heißt man würde aktiv
beispielsweise russische flugzeuge über
der ukraine abschießen man müsste auch
alles was ein was luftangriffe
ermöglichen würde flugfelder oder
boden-luft-raketen müsste man alles de
facto ausschalten das heißt das wäre ein
aktives eintreten in den krieg und damit
bestünde das risiko dass die nato in den
krieg mit russland eintritt und damit
möglicherweise eine noch größere
katastrophe
hervorruft als wir jetzt schon sehen und
in der abwägung ist das klar die
entscheidung vielen dank for mayor bis
hierhin wir werden später noch mal
weiter in der sendung sprechen und
vielen dank erstmal bis hierhin gern und
das einrichten von flucht korridoren
steht ja im raum seit vielen tagen hat
bisher nicht so richtig geklappt wäre
sicherlich auf der einen seite gut für
die menschen in den belagerten städten
aber vielleicht auch gut für die
russische armee und puten oder
einerseits sind es wirklich ist es
hervorragende idee weil es den leuten in
den belagerten städten helfen kann zu
fliehen das heißt dieser katastrophe zu
entgehen in der sie gerade leben und
weil das auch helfen kann humanitäre
hilfe in diese gebiete reinzukriegen was
wir aber befürchten dass russland
angeboten dass diese korridor nach
russland führen das heißt das land was
diese städte gerade bombardiert und
platt macht bietet sich als helfer an
das ist wirklich perfide das muss man
auch so ganz klar benennen das heißt das
ist kein ernstgemeintes angebot von
russland interesse hätte humanitäre
hilfe anzubieten dann würde man
flugkorridore in die ukraine anbieten
und nicht nach russland
was wir erleben und beobachten ist dass
einkesseln von den großen städten in der
ukraine durch russische truppen ist das
würden sie sagen ein gewisses muster in
bezug auf die kriegsführung dass
beispielsweise auch anna leeb oder
großen erinnert das ist in der tat ein
muster was für eine vergangenheit
gesehen haben und deswegen ist das so
beunruhigend was wir in syrien gesehen
haben war der ansatz eine stadt zu
belagern sie zu zermürben dann der
zivilbevölkerung anzubieten das sie über
humanitäre korridore gehen kann und dann
wurden die städte umso mehr zerstört und
alle bevölkerung die dort geblieben ist
wurde dann als legitimiertes ziele
angesehen dass man angreifen darf das
ist wirklich die idee des humanitären ad
absurdum geführt interessant ist ja dass
es immer noch relativ viele telefonate
gibt finde ich zwischen dem russischen
präsidenten und westlichen staatschefs
man erfährt er ganz wenig aus diesen
telefongesprächen was meinen sie oder
was hören sie auch was wird denn
jenseits dessen was man so hört dass
putin im prinzip also einen behauptungen
und bei seinen standpunkten bleibt was
wird da besprochen und was bringen diese
gespräch was genau besprochen wird das
wissen wir nicht aber dass diese
gespräche stattfinden ist wirklich gut
wenn man wirklich jeden kanal nutzen
sollte man muss sich aber auch nichts
vormachen es gibt die eine ebene wo man
sagen kann wir kriegen vielleicht ein
waffenstillstand in eine feuerpause
zwischen russland und der ukraine die
helfen kann dieses humanitäre leid zu
lindern
also nur momentane lösung die
langfristige politische lösung für den
konflikt welche zukunft hat die ukraine
wie werden die in zukunft miteinander
umgehen russland und die ukraine die ist
ein ganz weiter ferne wenn man aber
diese akute notlage hindern könnte und
die gespräche dabei helfen wäre das ein
enorm wichtiger schritt flüchtlinge in
den westen treiben zum einen
hätten sich viele menschen in den westen
zum anderen kann es doch aber auch zur
strategie von wladimir putin gehören ich
sage mal den westen mit diesem
flüchtlingsstrom zu destabilisieren oder
das zeigt nochmal dass dieser krieg in
den letzten tagen wirklich schmutziger
geworden ist und dass russland deutlich
rücksichtsvoller rücksichtsloser
tschuldigung und brutaler vorgeht das
heißt immer mehr das leid von
zivilpersonen in kauf nimmt immer mehr
in kauf nimmt dass die zivile
infrastruktur zerstört wird und völlig
brutal und rücksichtslos vorgeht um
seine ziele zu erreichen und das sollte
uns sehr beunruhigen vielleicht habe
noch nicht damit gerechnet wie geeint
der westen plötzlich auftritt wir
erleben hier einen absoluten
paradigmenwechsel was verteidigungs und
sicherheitspolitik angeht also das ist
ja wirklich eine historische wende über
die bundeswehr in deutschland haben wie
vorhin schon gesprochen aber warten wir
den blick vielleicht auf europa oder den
westen generell die müssen wir uns da
künftig neue aus aufrichten ausrichten
was die politik und den umgang mit
russland angeht ich glaube was ganz
wichtig ist dass die zeitenwende die
dass der kanzler gesagt die wir heute
sehen sich nicht nur auf die
sicherheitspolitik beschränkt sondern
dass wir wirklich eine umfassende
veränderung haben
egal wie der krieg ausgeht was wir
wissen ist dass wir in zukunft nicht
mehr kooperativ gemeinsam mit russland
in europa zusammenarbeiten werden
sondern dass wir von der kooperativen
friedensordnung die wir hatten eher in
eine konfrontative konflikt ordnung mit
russland gehen nicht weil wir das wollen
bei russland krieg in europa geführt hat
und dann müssen wir uns langfristig
fragen was heißt dass politisch wie
wollen wir mit diesem land
zusammenarbeiten was heißt das
wirtschaftlich wie werden wir uns an die
sanktionen aufstellen langfristig was
heißt das für unsere wirtschaft und was
heißt dass sicherheitspolitisch wie
können wir unsere ganzen strukturen
belastungs fähiger machen und wir müssen
wir auch möglichst unsere verteidigung
strukturen besser aufstellen um uns auch
selber schützen zu können gegen ein land
was gebetes krieg zu führen wenn sie
sagen konfrontative sicherheitspolitik
da sind wir ja auch gleich bei der frage
was ist wenn das eskaliert viele
menschen ich sehe das auch in meinem rad
haben angst und haben vielleicht sogar
auch angst vor einem atomkrieg ich frag
jetzt mal ganz einfach müssen wir angst
haben vor einem atomkrieg jeder konflikt
an der eine atommacht beteiligt ist wie
jetzt russland ist gefährlich und
deswegen ist dieses nukleare
säbelrasseln was wir von russland gehört
haben verantwortungslos und das muss uns
auch beunruhigen aber wir sollten nicht
in panik verfallen was wir bislang
gesehen haben ist vor allen dingen
säbelrasseln auf der rhetorischen ebene
das heisst drohungen aber die sind
bislang militärisch nicht untermauert
worden also die flugzeuge sind in
erhöhter alarmbereitschaft oder die
bomben sind nicht scharf gemacht worden
wir müssen das sehr ernst nehmen aber
die die botschaft von russland ist
bislang haltet euch raus mir ist das
wichtig aber nochmal wir müssen das
ernst nehmen sollten noch nicht in panik
verfallen weil das bislang auf der
politischen ebene stattfindet und
militärisch nicht hinterlegt ist die
frau major wir müssen noch über eine
sache sprechen denn die ukraine die ihr
fordern ja immer verzweifelter das
durchsetzen einer flugverbotszone die
nato sagt dazu bisher strikt nein jetzt
ist die frage wie kann die nato stärke
zeigen sich
engagieren die ukraine unterstützen ohne
sich militärisch gleichzeitig
einzumischen und wie interpretiert putin
dass auch also die die nato bislang
abgelehnt eine flugverbotszone
einzurichten weil das würde heißen aktiv
in den krieg eintreten das würde heißen
den luftraum über der ukraine de facto
frei zu schießen und das wäre ein
eintritt in den krieg mit russland das
wäre dann ein konflikt in dem de facto
atommächte beteiligt werden da ist das
risiko extrem groß dass wir in einem
noch größeren krieg reinkommen die nato
ist ein verteidigungsbündnis das heißt
die erste aufgabe ist es ihre eigenen
mitglieder das sind 30 staaten zu
schützen und vor allem die die besonders
exponiert sind also besonders der gefahr
ausgesetzt sind das sind vor allem die
staaten an der ostflanke polen die
baltischen staaten und an der
südostflanke das heißt rumänien und
bulgarien das heißt der fokus ist jetzt
wir schützen unsere mitglieder durch
aktivierung von verteidigungs plänen
durch truppenverstärkungen und das ist
gerade die hauptaufgabe die nato machen
muss seit beginn des krieges hat man ja
den eindruck es läuft nicht so wie
moskau sich das erhofft hat man weiß
auch nicht genau dieser konvoi 60
kilometer von kiew er stockt ja ein
bisschen ob das absicht ist oder ob er
nicht vorankommt hat denn die ukraine
überhaupt eine chance diesen konflikt
militärisch zu gewinnen
das ist schwer zu sagen weil in der tat
der russische fortschritte deutlich
deutlich langsamer war als wir das
gedacht hatten als viele das gedacht
haben und der ukrainische widerstand
deutlich größer war wahrscheinlich muss
man davon ausgehen dass angesichts der
der großen überzahl an gerät und auch an
an soldaten russland langfristig diesen
krieg gewinnen wird man muss aber auch
sagen selbst wenn sie militärisch
gewinnen haben sie den frieden nicht
gewonnen das heißt was danach kommt das
heißt ja nicht dass die situation
befriedet wäre das muss man auch ganz
ehrlich dazu sagen und deshalb ist ja
auch die frage wie kann eine
exit-strategie für putin möglicherweise
aussehen denn er muss ja irgendwie das
gefühl haben erhobenen kopfes
einigermaßen auf diese situation jetzt
heraus zu kommen was kann da eine lösung
seien aus seiner sicht also ich glaube
man muss zwei sachen unterscheiden
einmal deeskalation und einmal
konfliktlösung deeskalation heißt wir
schaffen uns vielleicht eine feuerpause
zu vereinbaren dass man die humanitären
notlage stoppen kann dass die dass die
flüchtlinge sich herauskommen das ist
vorstellbar da haben auch beide seiten
interesse daran die andere frage ist wie
kommen wir langfristig aus diesem
konflikt raus nämlich dass die ukraine
souverän bleiben möchte und russland die
ukraine vasallenstaat verwandeln möchte
zwischen diesen beiden maximalpositionen
findet mein com findet man kein
kompromiss das heißt wir müssen uns
langfristig darauf einstellen dass
dieser konflikt noch jahrelang uns in
europa beschäftigen wird weil russland
ganz klar gemacht hat sie werden nicht
von ihren forderungen abweichen
claudia war das sicherheits experte von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
fühlen dass sie den ganzen morgen weiter
dann bestimmen